this is representing the earth okay and
this represents what do you think yes
now our first challenge is how far apart
are they like roughly roughly okay oh I
guess maybe about that far maybe about
that much yeah yeah yeah maybe roughly
like roughly maybe I like that okay yeah
yeah maybe that I have a good like this
far
my feeling is like here somewhere rough
right there
all right all right let's let's say here
okay
tonight yeah yeah good see them with
pencils right here okay these are some
images I found on a Google image search
for the earth and the moon diagrams that
are not the scale are pretty common and
I understand why we make them so you can
show the detail without showing all that
uninteresting space in between but they
can have a problematic effect on
learning because they give people the
wrong idea about the relative proximity
of things now if we want to talk about
the distance between the Earth and the
moon it's actually it's about here think
about this it takes light one second to
go from the earth to the moon takes
eight minutes for light to travel to the
Sun and four years to go to our nearest
star and then consider that there are a
hundred billion stars in our galaxy and
as far as we know a hundred billion
galaxies in the universe so the universe
truly is bigger than we can imagine and
certainly bigger than we can draw it to
scale